you know it's funny when I saw Monsters
Inc the first thing I thought to myself
was yeah that was okay but I wonder what
they could do with a sequel I'm assuming
if you're watching this you know how the
first film ends so with that ending you
do kind of see a little bit of
possibility what if boo did grow up what
a Sullivan kept watching her what does
she became an adult who could actually
communicate with monsters or maybe when
she got to an age she didn't believe in
monsters anymore
maybe monsters would disappear maybe
it's something about losing childhood oh
my god this practically writes itself
but instead Pixar said it let's
just do a tease College movies yeah
because those to go so hand in hand
rather than being a sequel we have a
prequel showing how mike and sullivan
met up for the first time and of course
didn't get along each one thinks they're
gonna be the grey student and luster
university so naturally all sorts of
competition and comedic antics take
place but this menacing Dean decides she
doesn't like them yeah I don't entirely
know why she just kind of decides she
doesn't like them maybe because that's
what they do in 80s college movies I
don't know
and speaking of which if you've seen any
80s college movies I need any friggin
80s College movies you've seen monsters
you it's not a satire of 80s College
films that would be funny it's not doing
anything different with 80s College
films again that would be funny all it's
doing is taking the exact same
characters you've seen a million times
and replacing them with monsters the
bully jock the nerdy worm the
stick-in-the-mud Dean the quirky dorks
the need to make their frat house the
greatest frat house that there is and of
course all these people who don't get
along trying to find a way to get along
in the end I remember I saw the trailer
for this I thought it looked really
stupid but I also remember thing to
myself its Pixar Pixar the originators
of these incredible stories Finding Nemo
up The Incredibles the freakin Toy Story
films surely they wouldn't do something
as phoned-in as this but then I
remembered Cars 2 and got really
depressed outside of a few designs of
some of the monsters it's amazing the
lack of originality this film has
everything exists just to follow the
80's college movies tropes I remember
before seeing Muppets Most Wanted they
had a short based on monsters you and
you know what it was a million times
more interesting they took advantage of
their environment and did something new
with it though he promised that was just
a few minutes long this is an hour and a
friggin half it's easily one of the most
boring Pixar films I've ever sat through
you can predict every joke you can
predict every moment that's gonna happen
it's just it's why was this deserving of
so much time and effort to go into it
the only new thing that pops up in this
film is the ending and without giving
away too much it is probably the only
really good thing in it it's kind of the
idea that you don't need to follow the
traditional path that everybody else
does but it's done in a way that's
actually kind of clever and probably
hits close to home for a lot of people
in fact if I had to guess I would assume
this whole film was made just so it
could get this message across it's a
message you don't see much in movies and
especially in animated family films well
then I guess we have the Pixar
equivalent of Meet the Robinsons
something that has a really good message
but not the best means of displaying it
but he'll even Meet the Robinsons was so
strange and bizarre you could kind of
admire it for how odd it is this is more
like a textbook about how they made
animal house
hell even watching a movie about the
making of animal house would be more
interesting than watching this I've had
a lot of fans upset with me that I
didn't like this film but I'm sorry I
just think it's awful I tried to go in
with a clear mind I tried to open up to
the idea that this could somehow work
but it just sucks out all the funny all
the originality all the interesting
characters all the neat story ideas for
such a stale experience I guess there's
nothing bad in it in terms of stuff that
be like offensive or unwatchable for
your kids but for anyone who's an adult
and has seen 80s college movies to death
and wants to move on to something else
this is a definite film to scare you
away